[Music]
let's go to alicia in
philadelphia where i was born and raised
the playgrounds where i spent most of my
days how are we doing
hey how's it going hey good how are you
i'm doing pretty good can't complain yes
you could you'd be like everybody else
but you're not and that's so great
so good hey so what's up how can i help
i have a bit of a loaded question for
you john oh i love loaded questions did
we used to hang out when i was a kid
make just let me know that if i'm about
to get canceled
nothing i know of maybe in a past life
i'm always afraid that an old friend of
mine is going to call me like i got a
loaded question for you remember that
time i'll be like well this show's over
so what's up uh
less loaded than that um so my question
is is therapy not for everyone
tell me more
so
i was diagnosed with bipolar 2 disorder
when i was a freshman in college which
was about eight years ago now okay and
since then i have probably seen seven
different therapists
with really no success um i haven't
found one yet that i feel is really
therapeutic and i've kind of said to
myself you know maybe it's me maybe i'm
doing something wrong so i really
switched it up
i would give each therapist anywhere
between six months to a year to give the
process the full chance that it has
i've tried different genders
of therapists i've tried different
approaches from talk therapy to cvt
i've tried different formats i've tried
online i've tried in person and i keep
finding myself in the same situation
after like the fourth or fifth session
where i just feel like i'm not really
getting anything out of it i don't have
any breakthroughs um and
i just
i don't know john i just feel like i
keep getting into the same rut
and i'm not sure if it's just my
personality isn't very conducive to the
therapy environment or maybe it's
something that i'm doing
well one
dude that's not a loaded question at all
that's a great question good for you
and number two
dude
like the fact that you are willing to
step out and go hey i'm looking at all
of these things and there's one common
denominator it's me maybe it's me
that's a that's a level of reflection
that many don't ever make it to so good
for you like that like that's great
um let me ask you this what are you
like why would you go to counseling why
would you go um what are you hoping to
get out of it
it's a good question um one of the
things i've tried to do with the last
two
is do exactly what i think you're asking
is like what are the actual objectives
that you have for going
and i found that
there's kind of like three for me
um the first is dealing with any
childhood baggage that i still have that
i haven't had the chance to really go
through myself
the second is dealing with
some things that i've noticed trigger my
bipolar disorder pretty bad so whether
it be like imposter syndrome at work
or
executive dysfunction in my life and the
last
is usually around relationships
and how to better foster those because i
also have a lot of
difficulties with that in my life i'm a
very private person i'm like i'm like
the mysterious friend that everyone has
just like i'm the friend that i ask
thousands of questions but i don't
really answer them myself so why
why have you chosen that identity
that's a great question i
i don't know um
it's just something that feels very
comfortable for me yeah it serves you in
some way what is it
um less judgment for sure right you
can't be judged if people don't really
know much about you but you get to be
the judge of everybody which is awesome
yeah it really benefits me yes
um so
like can i ask you a couple of hard
questions yeah i mean i asked you when i
think that's fair oh you asked me you
gave me a softball no that was awesome
um
at this point
what childhood baggage do you not know
about
that's a good point
i mean i lived through it is there
anything unspoken
um in what way do you mean can you
rephrase uh did you have childhood
trauma of some sort
yeah so i had um my father is extremely
um
mentally ill he's
not only as bipolar but also
schizophrenia so my i had a very chaotic
childhood
from just parents that didn't really
know how to
parent and also just didn't have the
mental stability to be able to do it
successfully
and you know underneath that so number
one yes that is a
major major trauma
having a chaotic childhood but
underneath that
you have a brain that never learned how
to connect with somebody else
yeah i think that's fair and
that disconnection betw from a person to
another person
is
the chief alarm that's going to go off
over and over and over again and then
when you start to connect then your
brain remembers oh yeah this is
dangerous we've been down this road
before and so you just get in that loop
you know what i mean i gotta connect
gotta connect we're connecting whoa we
can't do that and then we're off to the
races again
yeah is that fair sounds like me
yeah and then you go up and down toggle
up and down up and down up and down but
here's the thing i want to i want to
lean on you know that
fair
yeah i think so so
give me off the top of your head two or
three triggers immediately go
um
so the first one that's
like screaming in my mind is
feeling judged um okay
the i guess the other one
is
um
i don't know
the feeling judge one just seems so big
in my mind that it almost takes up like
two or three spots why like i don't i i
think it's something i i think one one
of the things from my childhood not only
from my parents but from other facets of
my life too
um
i i've like
i just never really had a chance so like
when i was born i was born with a birth
defect so i was already like in an
outcast kind of situation
and then i grew up with parents who were
super chaotic and i was known as like
the kid in the neighborhood from like
that crazy house and um
and then as i got older i started
gaining a lot of weight i was the chubby
kid like that was an outcast
um and then as i got older than that i
found out i was gay that was an outcast
so i i think i found myself like the
less i tell people about myself or my
surroundings like the less i'll be
judged
so can i push on that
come from yeah
the name of my new book i don't even
know if i'm allowed to say it can i say
it here's the name of the new book
my new book
it's like you're setting me up here i i
i'll send you i'm gonna send you a free
copy it didn't come out for a few months
but you're like setting me up here
the name of the book is own your past
change your future
and here's where most mental health
practitioners get stuck and more
importantly here's where most
mental health clients can get stuck
is you know your past
those things happened
they are real
and then what is next
is up to you
and it sounds to me like you have made
an identity out of what happened in the
past and that identity prohibits you
from living a rambunctious joyful
exciting adventurous life
and every day is some sort of reckoning
or trying to reconcile a past that can't
be reconciled it just is and there's a
period at the end of that sentence
and it sounds like you spent the last
eight nine 10 20 years trying to go back
and edit that sentence that can't be
edited instead of using that energy to
write something new
hear what i'm saying
yeah i hear what you're saying and so as
somebody who's got my own triggers for a
number of things
the key to moving forward in your life
is leaning into the triggers until they
don't trigger you anymore not running
from them
so the key if you have a traumatic abuse
of childhood
is
i think the the the name of the book
seeking safety finding safety
you work with a counselor for 12 to 16
sessions
or that's where the whole maps thing
with uh it's like whatever the
path you take the goal is i can think
about those things that happen to me i
can remember them and my body doesn't
take off on me
that's the choice to heal
that you could say man i was judged and
i was abused i was neglected i grew up
in a chaotic home i don't even have a
picture of what love looks like
and
i'm gonna go find it
and i am worth being loved and i'm worth
laughing and i'm worth having an
adventure and i'm worth people finding
out all of me
and still loving me anyway
that's where it becomes a choice
tomorrow becomes a choice today becomes
a choice the past you can't it is
so my question for you is
i think if you go to a therapist to get
the magic sentence that's going to go ah
that's it like the good will hunting
moment
where he's like it's not your fault and
you hug and he's like oh and i'm going
to go
i'm going to go see about a girl it's
my one my favorite movies of all time
that's not how therapy usually works
it sounds what you need is somebody to
hold you accountable to a as you
practice a new identity
and the identity would be i am worthy of
being loved and you know what practice
is someone holding you accountable
accountable is a fancy word for judge
oh boy
you're gonna have to get a counselor or
a therapist or a psychologist or a
friend or a mentor or a coach somebody
who will sit with you and you say
i am gonna start treating my body right
and that will look like on most days i'm
gonna eat well and i'm gonna exercise
come hell or high water i'm taking care
of my body
i am going to journal my negative
thoughts
i'm going to write them down and i'm
going to email them to you every day and
if i don't you're going to call me which
is a form of judgment and then your
trigger you're gonna trigger and you're
gonna either go
way up or way down and you're gonna have
to say no i'm gonna be in the middle of
this are you still taking your
medication
yes i am okay so i'm gonna continue to
take care of take my meds i'm gonna
continue to do the things that are gonna
help me be well but here's what i want
you to hear
you're practicing this new stuff because
you've never done it before
and this is much more about
physical practice than it is cognitive
practice i think you've cognitively
practiced yourself into the ground is
that fair
yeah i think so do you think a lot
sounds like you've thought a lot for the
last 10 years
yeah i think i'm like i'm a very very i
think you've also noticed i'm a very
reflective person yes
but you spend so much time in reflection
that you're letting every day go by
underneath you
yeah like you're driving forward by
looking in the rear view mirror
and i'd love for you to look out the
windshield it's so much bigger
there's so much awesome stuff ahead of
you if you will let yourself be loved
and that means you have to let yourself
have risk and that means you have to let
yourself get hurt again
and that to answer your original
questions what a counselor can do
many people don't know why they feel the
way they feel i think you know
what a counselor could help you do
or a friend or a coach right could help
you then say okay
what happens next i want to practice
what happens next
and here's the here's the simple
like the simple truth and this is
ancient and this is neuroscience it's
everything in between
here's the three things you can control
you can get connected to a group of
people that care about you and love you
that could be one person that could be
five people
you can change your thoughts and you can
change your actions and that's it
how does that sound
it sounds doable
i mean i i think um i'm i'm down for
anything right like i'm at a point where
i know something's got to give i just
don't really know what has to give okay
so i think you i think you've helped
give me a bit of a clearer path of what
that could look like i would love you to
give council one more try
and i want you to set a series of
identity goals
and this comes from james clear stuff
it's
i think it's one of the wisest
sentiments i've heard in the last decade
here's what it is when you're going to
change your life you're going to change
your behaviors change your actions
change your habits whatever that looks
like
start with who i want to be
and then reverse engineer it because
most of us start with i want to lose 20
pounds
i want to start dating i want to go on
four dates this month i want we we set
these arbitrary numerical goals
and man we can all grit our teeth and
and grind out 10 pounds
but it just comes right back because
we're the same person
the way to do this sustainably is to say
i'm the kind of person
who's a steward of their body
i'm the kind of person who's the steward
of their mind i take care of my brain
what does that mean that's going to
impact what i watch how much i sleep
not scrolling the internet 24 7.
taking a class at the local library for
free on how to knit or tile or bathroom
i mean whatever it's going to be
i'm going to invest in myself i'm a guy
who goes who says yes and goes on
adventures that's the one for me because
i have a tendency to get exhausted and
turn into a recluse
and one of my core identities is i will
say yes to adventures i ended up on an
adventure this weekend alicia dude
dude it was bananas and when i got home
i was so glad i did it my son on the way
home he was like dad can you believe we
just did that i was like nope but we did
right um it made no sense
like
like physically my sleep none of it made
sense and it was awesome and we will
talk about that story for years so i say
yes because if i just said i need to do
three things i wouldn't do it
but i'm a guy who does those things so
now i'm gonna end up in that space so i
want you to come up with three to five
identities here's who i'm gonna be
and then i want you to take that to a
counselor and say i need to build a plan
that you will help hold me accountable
to
and we're not focusing on the past as
much anymore because you know
now we're focusing on moving forward and
you
have to become okay with being in a
relationship with someone who can hold
you accountable that's life
sounds like a plan john
do you promise
no yeah seriously i will will you write
me back and say you're full of crap do
it in your one of your low seasons like
i
getting a look get a low letter from
somebody with bipolar is one of the most
harrowing yet awesome things because it
is so caustic and after you read it
you're like oh oh my
and then a few weeks later you talked to
him like i didn't mean that and then
you're like wait what what
so you wait
you know what i'm talking about you sent
those right
me no never
yes i love it
so
you promise you'll a
how about this here's here's the thing
just for the listener i want you to
write down your five identities and i
want you to email them to me
i'm going to read them on the internets
we're all going to hold you accountable
your game all right
i'm game yeah let's do it all right and
then you're going to go find one more
you're going to give one more shot
and you're going to say i want to become
this person and that means i need some
help with my nutrition i need some help
with exercise help with my mental health
help and
purchasing a pear tree and we're going
to make this thing happen you in
i'm yeah i'm totally in this is my next
adventure this is the next adventure why
because you're a person who goes on
adventures can that be one
yeah
and what if one of them was you're a
person who doesn't mind being judged
what is that yeah what was that
then people would say why'd you wear
that and you could then go i don't know
because i like it or you could go yeah
that was dumb i won't wear that anymore
and then you just brush your shoulders
off and move on about your day because
it doesn't mean you're not a great
awesome wonderful person
does that feel pretty ideal yeah it's
not ideal it's just reality so we're
just gonna choose that and we're gonna
practice it and then we start when
someone says oh my gosh
why are you dating that person
then your heart takes off on you and you
start to go
then you just get curious and go why is
my body taken oh
judger i'm a person who doesn't mind
being judged cool thanks for sharing
thank you idiot fair
yes be curious be curious
and change your identities
get connected
change your thoughts change your actions
freedom
can we do that can we be braveheart here
for a second alicia now you're solving
for freedom you're awesome